la séance est reprise notre ordre du
jour appelle les explications de vote
des groupes et le vote par scrutin
public solennelle sur le projet de loi
relatif à l'accélération des procédures
liées à la construction de nouvelles
installations du nucléaires
à proximité de sites nucléaires
existants et au fonctionnement des
installations existantes je rappelle mes
chers collègues que la procédure
accélérée a été engagée sur ce texte
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je vous rappelle que ce scrutin
s'effectuera depuis les terminaux de
vote
et oui je vous invite à vous assurer que
vous disposez bien de votre carte de
vote à vérifier que celle-ci fonctionne
correctement
en l'insérant dans votre terminal de
vote
et en cas de difficultés vous appelez
les huissiers
mais avant de passer au vote mes chers
collègues je vais donner la parole à
ceux de nos collègues qui ont été
inscrits pour nous expliquer les raisons
de leur vote je vous rappelle le
principe 7 minutes par groupe 3 minutes
pour un collecter d'appartenant à aucun
groupe et je vais donner la parole
immédiatement au président Jean-Claude
Roquier pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
je suis le président
monsieur le Président d'analyse mais
chers collègues la France a attendu que
les effets du réchauffement climatique
se passer ressentir et puis de force et
surtout la sécurité d'approvisionnement
en énergie se fragilise pour relancer en
fait les Leclerc les élargies
renouvelables que le temps perdu qui
nous impose désormais de légiférer dans
l'urgence pour se mettre pas et
rattraper plus de 20 ans d'inerties afin
de préserver notre souveraineté
électrique nous savons comme disait si
bien jeune fédéral Kennedy la victoire à
samppère mais la défaite est orpheline
cependant ces choses se penser du passé
car les débats ont révélé on oublie des
responsabilités collectives un rabâchage
et des postures idéologiques
mais les revirements ne constituent pas
une spécificité nationale l'Allemagne ou
encore la Belgique ont repoussé la
sortie du nucléaire la Suède et le
Pays-Bas procède à sa relance quand
d'autres comme la Pologne se lance dans
la réalité c'est une dernière année le
démontre puis on a la diversification
plus on maîtrise les énergies les
incertitudes en termes d'accès aux
matières critiques de technologie ou de
coûts toutes ces énergies décarbonées
dans la ravage et la inconvénient c'est
un pari que nous faisons car l'équation
est complexe un mix 100% renouvelable
d'ici 2050 ne serait pas tenable c'est
non seulement ils sont écoutés mais il
serait irréalisable puisque nous ne
disposons pas des moyens de stockage
c'est-à-dire qu'ils étaient nécessaires
pour pallier leur intermittence même si
les investissements sont l'hydrogène
connaissent un coût d'accélérateur en
raison du nouveau contexte géopolitique
il nous faut trouver une certaine
souplesse pour adapter les objectifs de
politique énergétique à ce contexte aux
fraises sociaux économiques et
financiers et au rides avancées de
l'innovation qui ne peuvent pas se
décréter les choix des passés s'imposent
pour l'avenir on ne peut faire table
rase d'une réalité qui impose à nous qui
s'impose à nous le mixte électrique
français repose à 70% sur l'énergie
nucléaire par ailleurs les efforts de
sobriété dont est également être
poursuivis en parallèle si on ne veut
pas sombrer dans la décroissance en
effet les premiers réacteurs réacteurs
euper 2 ne seront pas disponibles avant
2035 2037 au mieux pour revenir au coeur
du débat ce projet de loi contribuera à
accélérer la procédure administrative en
matière de construction des nouveaux
réacteurs et prévenir les contentieux en
limitant les occasions de former des
recours dilatoires sans pour autant
modifier les règles de fond
et d'autorisation de création le choix
des implantés sur les sites existants ou
alors proximité immédiate renforcera
lacialtabilité des projets mais aussi la
réussite les territoires états déjà
prédisposés pour les accueillir c'est le
cas de la centrale du Blayais cher notre
collègue Nathalie Delattre à l'issue de
nos travaux le texte a été complété
notamment par l'intégration de petit
réacteurs modulaire l'extension de la
durée d'application des mesures de 15 à
27 ans la prise en compte des
observations des collectivités et les
améliorations portées à la consultation
du public sont les bienvenus en revanche
la question de la fermeture du cycle du
combustible éloigné d'être réglé si je
regrette l'abandon du projet Astrid
nucléaire de quatrième génération
réacteur qui permettrait de mettre en
cause la stratégie apportée par la
France à la
une meilleure prise en compte du
diablement climatique et les
cyberattaques nous regrettons que le
périmètre des plans particuliers
d'intervention n'est pas été élargi
comme le proposait notre collègue
Véronique et
la résolutions
cumulés par notre pays qui n'a plus
construit un seul réacteur depuis 20 ans
les déboires du chantier flavonville
peuvent servir d'épouvantail ce texte
demeure symbolique à son contenu des
obstacles qui ne rêvent pas les
procédures persistantes
outre les difficultés du recrutement à
résoudre il faudra préciser rapidement
le volet relatif au montage financier à
notre quelle régulation du marché
électricité en France et en Europe sera
appliqué le mécanisme d'accès régulier à
l'énergie nucléaire historique la reine
qui doit prendre fin en 2025 ne protège
ni les constructeurs français ni EDF
lourdement d'été à la veille de sa
nationalisation
le marché d'énergie doit être réformé on
ne peut continuer la subventionner les
fourniestérales la concurrence pour la
concurrence sans aucune incitation à
l'investissement oui un jour en été mais
oui il y a une solidarité au niveau
européen et a plus d'équité un petit mot
sur le calendrier
la concertation publique arrive soit
trop tôt sans trop tard trop tard
qu'elle aurait dû avoir lieu il y a
plusieurs années trop tôt car le
disposons pas des études et te
faisabilité et la liste des sites
d'implantations ainsi que du coup total
du programme de relance une nucléaire et
laissez modalités de financement si
facile d'activer les objectifs dans la
loi ceci doit être réaliste le débat
public se poursuit actuellement et la
représentation nationale aura l'occasion
de s'en saisir que l'on soit favorable
ou non les amandes ira porteurs oui à
supprimer le plafonnement de la part du
nucléaire à 50% en 2035 on compte que
peu présenté ce débat
cela étant cet ajout ne constitue pas
pour nous une ligne rouge gageons que
l'architecture générale des choix
énergies de la France disposant de ces
murs porteurs d'ici la fin de cette
année ainsi le groupe RDSE votera
favorablement en faveur du projet de loi
merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Gérard
Longuet pour le groupe les républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues d'abord il faut
remercier la Conférence des présidents
du Sénat d'avoir inscrit ce projet de
loi l'adoption de ce projet de loi je le
souhaite profondément à la procédure du
scrutin solennel cela permet sur un
texte majeur d'avoir l'attention de
l'immense majorité de notre assemblée
c'est important je remercie d'ailleurs
le groupe des Républicains de m'avoir
confié la responsabilité de défendre ce
texte c'est un texte extrêmement
important alors madame le ministre en
apparence c'est un test à l'origine
technique qui se proposait avec trois
types de mesures différentes
d'accélérer les procédures toujours trop
longues dans notre pays pour les
dossiers les plus complexes comme
d'ailleurs les dossiers les plus simples
et de gagner 56 mois dit-on sur la
construction d'un réacteur nucléaire
avec des objectifs que notre excellent
rapporteur Daniel premiers que je
cherche du regard
a parfaitement défendu faire en sorte
qu'il y ait plus de sécurité
non mais on en reparlera plus tard si
vous voulez
c'est quand même l'avenir de notre pays
et puis on va on va en parler beaucoup
c'est moi qui viennent alors il faut
mieux s'y préparer dès maintenant donc
sécurité cybersécurité et risque
climatique on fait l'objet de soutien de
vos mesures et enrichissement parfait de
la même façon nous sommes efforcés et
pour les représentants des élus que nous
sommes d'associer mieux les
collectivités locales et de faire en
sorte que des dispositions particuliers
d'urbanisme et notamment le zan ne soit
pas décidé sans qu'il soit associé à la
formule c'est donc un véritable une
bonne orientation madame la ministre
mais un véritable enrichissement que
notre rapporteur nous a proposé
d'adopter et que nous avons soutenu
j'ajoute enfin
que nous avons sur cette affaire de
[Musique]
de sécurité jouer l'allongement des
procédures mon excellent collègue qui
vient de l'afficher en passant de 15 à
25 ans nous avons un ensemble
d'amendements qui renforce la sécurité
et qui apporte une sécurité juridique
indispensable c'est le troisième point
que je vous ai évoqué dans ces sécurités
une sécurité juridique indispensable
tant il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ce sont
souvent des procédures administratives
contradictoires qui paralyse notre
projet le projet gouvernemental enrichi
par la Commission et adoptée par notre
assemblée en effet va à la fois
consolider les projets associés les élus
et les populations et en définitive
répondre à l'adaptation de ces réacteurs
anciens et nous allons maintenant
attaquer le point qui nous qui pourrait
non pas nous opposer mais nous
distinguer
notre excellente ancienne collègue
madame Jouanneau qui est aujourd'hui
présidente de la Commission nationale du
débat public déclare dans la presse que
le Sénat n'est pas dans son rôle qu'il
préhende la discussion publique sur la
discussion nationale sur la stratégie
nucléaire et aurait souhaité que nous
nous taisions je pense que Madame
Jouanneau est en dehors des réalités
pourquoi parce que en
dénovembre 2017 et je serai bref dès
novembre 2017 le président de la
République a remis en cause en fait la
loi de transition énergétique et de
croissance verte sous l'empire de
laquelle nous sommes encore aujourd'hui
il faut quand même le rappeler ce kit
profondément absurde en décidant de
repousser et il avait raison à 2035 le
plafond
issu de la loi de 2015
portant à 50% l'électricité d'origine
nucléaire donc le débat était ouvert
pour être très honnête il est lent ce
débat puisque nous avons eu une
déclaration à Belfort en novembre
2021 qui était pas mal je me suis dit
tiens ça bouge enfin le nucléaire va
être à l'ordre du jour et le 10 février
2022 le président de la République nous
présente un programme complet avec ça
avec son son oratoire tout particulier
qui est parlé interminablement sur du
sujet qui est censé connaître absolument
parfaitement or cela n'est pas vrai cela
n'est pas vrai parce qu'il aurait dû
poser la question principale en matière
d'énergie aujourd'hui s'agit-il d'abord
de décarboner ou s'agit-il de verdir
s'il s'agit de verdir le la majorité
sénatoriale considère que ce n'est plus
la priorité l'urgence climatique exige
de décarboner notre société à travers le
logement la mobilité l'industrie et pour
décarboner il faut électrifier et à ce
moment-là la proposition du Président de
la République est diminué de 40%
la production
énergétique et simplement irréaliste
même si en revanche son idée d'augmenter
de 60% la production électrique est
pertinente sauf qu'ils s'en donnent pas
les moyens car pour augmenter de 60% la
production électrique ce ne sont pas si
réacteurs de nouvelles formules EPR 2
plus éventuellement 8 et la certitude
que l'on va maintenir 100% des capacités
existantes ce qui n'apparaît pas
vraisemblable aujourd'hui jusqu'en 2050
excusez-moi du peu comme ministre de
l'Industrie et signé un réac le dernier
réacteur celui-ci vaut en
1994 et bien c'est le réacteurs qui sont
de bonne bêtes et qui travaillent bien
elles vont fatiguer quand même et il
faudra d'une façon ou d'une autre si on
ne voulait remplacer que la moitié des
réacteurs existants d'ici
2050 il faudrait sans doute au-delà des
des 6 plus 8,14 sans doute entre 20 et
25 réacteurs de type 750 MW pour arriver
à un résultat et donc le Sénat a eu
raison d'ouvrir ce débat et je remercie
de notre cannelle Gremillet et Madame
Sophie prima d'avoir lancé cette
ouverture nous attendons avec impatience
la proposition de loi puisque nous
allons quitter le domaine du
réglementaire pour avoir une sorte de
PPE législative nous attendons avec
impatience cette loi parce que nous
voudrions savoir quelle est la stratégie
faudra rappeler que il y a une vieille
histoire en
1975 je vais notaire monsieur le
Président nous avions le même débat au
Sénat je n'étais pas encore sénateur
j'étais
commissaire du Gouvernement et bien le
ministre avait expliqué à cette époque
le 14 mai 1975 c'était Michel d'Ornano
qui mettait en œuvre sous l'autorité du
président Giscard d'Estaing la politique
de Pierre Messmer
vous la continuité française de lisait
la stratégie appartient au Parlement la
mise en œuvre au gouvernement donc je
revendiquons la stratégie merci
la parole est à notre collègue Pierre
baie de vielle pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoire
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le général de Gaulle
en 1963 qualifié déjà l'énergie atomique
comme le fond de l'activité de demain
que de chemin parcourus depuis le prix
Nobel de Pierre et Marie Curie associé
Henri Becquerel pour la découverte de la
radioactivité naturelle
le nucléaire c'est l'histoire de la
France de ses physiciens visionnaires et
innovants c'est une aventure
industrielle une aventure d'excellence
et d'indépendance énergétique
en plus d'être une énergie respectueuse
du climat le nucléaire fourni une
électricité en continu capable s'adapter
aux variations de la demande électrique
par la stabilité de son réseau et son
caractère pilotable il contribue
largement à sécuriser l'acheminement
électrique dans les hôpitaux dans les
entreprises et dans chaque foyer
de notre force historique il ne restait
là que l'absolu nécessité de
reconstruire une filière largement
malmenée ces dernières années
entre hésitation coupable et accident
spectaculaire nous avons
considérablement revu à la baisse nos
ambitions dans ce secteur
si ces colonnes royales et ses acolytes
ont manqué de réalisme et de vision si
collectivement nous n'avons pas
suffisamment soutenu cette filière
l'heure doit être aujourd'hui à des
choix
clairs et forts n'oublions pas que nos
centrales nucléaires sont la principale
source de production d'électricité des
carbonée malgré nos 87% d'électricité
d'origine nucléaire en 2010 nous sommes
reposés sur nos lauriers en négligeant
coupablement des autres modes de
production
nous discutons beaucoup de bouquets de
mixtes mais les leçons des deux chocs
pétroliers de 73 et 79 n'ont pas été
retenus et nous sommes toujours
dépendants à 70% des énergies fossiles
le déclenchement de la guerre en Ukraine
nous l'a rappelé cruellement
l'équation en résoudre et limpide il
nous faut davantage nucléaire et
davantage d'énergie renouvelable si nous
voulons décarboner nos transports et nos
habitudes de vie au quotidien
je profite de ce point pour soulever le
travail important réalisé par la
ministre et son cabinet et les sénateurs
impliqués lors du projet de loi relatif
à l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable à cette occasion
je tiens à rappeler que nous avons
entendu la principale critique derrière
laquelle un certain nombre de
parlementaires de tout bord se sont
cachés pour ne pas voter ce texte
notamment à l'Assemblée l'argument est
purement chronologique ils auraient
préféré que la loi de programmation plus
granuelle de l'énergie était discutés en
amont nous sommes tous d'accord mais
l'invasion de l'Ukraine nous a conduit
dans une situation d'urgence énergétique
absolue qui exigeait des réponses
efficaces et rapides
oui ces textes d'accélération ne sont
peut-être pas totalement suffisants mais
ils sont essentiels pour définir un cas
pertinent
en ce qui concerne le nucléaire ce texte
en l'état propose des avancées notoires
dans la simplification des procédures et
le raccourcissement des délais gagner du
temps ou en perdre moins voilà l'enjeu
tout d'abord nous sommes très nombreux
sur les bandes de cette hémicycle en
nous réjouir de la suppression au sein
du code de l'énergie de l'objectif de
réduction en 50% de la part du nucléaire
notre bouquet énergétique à l'horizon
2035 cet objectif qui relève du fantasme
comme le précédent de François Hollande
qui était fixé en 2025 notre groupe a
démontré son attachement à cette
abrogation dès l'examen en commission de
plus la recherche et l'innovation dans
le domaine de l'hydrogène ma carbone
font partie des objectifs à long terme
enfin plusieurs garanties sont ajoutés
concernant la sûreté et la sécurité des
installations face aux aléas du
dérèglement climatique être toujours
plus transparent et prévoyant doit
rester notre préoccupation essentielle
si l'opinion publique a très
favorablement évolué dans ce domaine
l'acceptation totale des Français n'est
pas au rendez-vous c'est la raison pour
laquelle la sécurité et la sûreté
nucléaire
doivent rester plus que jamais notre
priorité
la France en matière de prévention a mis
la barre beaucoup plus haut que les
autres pays
grâce aux nouvelles évolutions
technologiques comme les réacteurs
moyenmodules le projet ITER et même la
fusion toutes les conditions sont
réunies pour donner un véritable second
souffle à cette filière qui combinait à
l'énergie solaire doit nous amener dans
quelques dizaines d'années à ce graal
que l'indépendance énergétique
mais le défi ne pourra être relevé que
si nous faisons de la question de
l'enseignement et de la formation des
personnels ingénieurs une priorité
absolue je sais que le gouvernement est
engagé sur le sujet avec 200 millions
d'euros investis dans la formation
depuis 2019 poursuivons dans ce sens le
manque flagrant d'équipe compétente dans
le domaine de la maintenance à
considérablement ralenti la remise en
service d'un grand nombre de réacteurs
depuis le début de la crise énergétique
le meilleur d'innovation dans ce secteur
reste encore à inventé il récent succès
des Américains dans le domaine de la
fusion nous autorise tous les espoirs
enfin le redressement de notre économie
et de nos comptes publics sera
directement lié à nos ambitions en
matière d'indépendance énergétique le
nucléaire l'une des sources
d'électricité des carbonées beaucoup
plus à produire permettant à la France
d'avoir un prix d'électricité parmi les
plus bas d'euros n'écoutons pas les
merveilles les prédicateurs lampes à
huile dont le discours irréaliste ne
peut que nous conduire dans des impasses
mortifères pour les générations futures
le groupe Les Indépendants sera sans
ambiguïté et votera ce texte symbole
fort d'un CAP à tracer et à poursuivre
je vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Daniel
salmon pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues ce texte a changé de
nature il traduit maintenant le
programme politique des républicains
avec le consentement du gouvernement
un programme qu'ils auraient dû lancer
quand ils étaient au pouvoir pour avoir
de nouveaux réacteurs opérationnels
aujourd'hui si tentait que le Pr est
démarré un jour ce projet de loi n'est
pas une loi de programmation avez-vous
assisté madame la ministre durant tout
le parcours de ce texte au Sénat il
n'était pas censé préempter des
décisions qui seraient prises sur
l'avenir du mix énergétique français
pourtant au détour d'un amendement
l'objectif très vague de diversification
du mix électrique en visant en meilleure
équilibre entre le nucléaire et les e NR
vous avez acté il finit le renoncement à
l'objectif de réduction à 50% de la part
du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité nous regrettons
profondément ce recul conséquent et
grave pour l'avenir énergétique de notre
pays le nucléaire demande une stabilité
à toute épreuve alors que le monde vit
et va vivre des décennies avec de
grandes turbulences climatiques et
géopolitiques c'est un choix dogmatique
qui nous engage de mariée de manière
irréversible pour le siècle à venir au
mépris du processus démocratique et
déconcertation en cours alors qu'il est
aujourd'hui crucial que les citoyens
décident eux-mêmes de leur avenir sur
cet enjeu majeur
d'ailleurs le président du débat public
sur la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs Monsieur Michel Badré et la
présidente de la Commission nationale du
débat public Madame Chantal Jouanno je
pense une démocrate se désole également
de ce procédé complètement
antidémocratique qui revient à
considérer je cite comme sans intérêt
les interrogations les remarques et les
propositions faites par nos concitoyens
cela a l'air de contenter certains avec
la suppression de l'objectif de 50% qui
est remplacé par une part de nucléaires
dans la production électrique à plus de
50% à l'horizon 2050 le code de
l'énergie a été modifié et nous passons
du principe d'un plafond à celui d'un
plancher cela change tout ce changement
de paradigme nous engage dans un futur
particulièrement incertain
cette mesure s'accompagne de tout un
panel de dispositifs pour une relance
maximaliste du nucléaire sans la moindre
nuance suppression du plafond de 63,2
gigawatts de capacité nucléaire
installée révision du décret qu'il
prévoit la fermeture de 12 réacteurs en
plus de Fessenheim prolongement de la
durée de l'application du texte à 2050
initialement prévu à 208 qualification
de projets d'intérêt général par un
décret en Conseil d'État pour les
projets d'installation d'entreposage de
combustible nucléaire ou encore
durcissement des peines punissant les
intrusions au sein des centrales
nucléaires plutôt que de renforcer la
sécurité des centrales on préfère sans
prendre au lanceur d'alerte les
militants de Greenpeace à travers ses
actions dénonce justement les problèmes
de sécurité des sites nucléaires
casser le thermomètre n'a jamais fait
tomber la fièvre du malade bref des
mesures strictement à l'opposé de nos
recommandations rappelons les objectifs
de ce texte un projet de loi qui vise à
gagner du temps en simplifiant les
procédures administratives jusqu'à 56
mois dites-vous même si le Conseil
d'État lui-même n'est pas vraiment
d'accord or encore une fois ce ne sont
pas les procédures environnementales qui
ont fait prendre du retard à la filière
le problème du nucléaire est beaucoup
plus profond notamment un problème de
compétence mise en évidence par le
fiasco de l'EPR de Flamanville et
clairement nous ne cernons toujours pas
l'intérêt de ce texte face à l'urgence
climatique avec des premiers réacteurs
opérationnels en 2040 il sera bien trop
tard faire des mesures pour gagner
quelques mois ne sert absolument à rien
le GIEC ne cesse de marteler que les
principaux investissements dans la
transition énergétique doivent être
faits dans les 10 ans pourquoi
n'entendez toujours pas tu
n'entendez-vous toujours pas cet
argument rationnel et scientifique
nous partons à l'aveugle sur ces choix
de construire plusieurs EPM qui
représentent plusieurs dizaines de
milliards d'euros d'investissement cet
argent nous en avons besoin maintenant
pour développer les installations
d'énergie renouvelables et pour
atteindre des objectifs d'efficacité
énergétique
là où on le sait là où on le sait que
l'on peut agir concrètement pour la
planète maintenant et pour le
portefeuille des Français c'est bien
dans ses ENR et dans l'efficacité
énergétique les énergies renouvelables
deviennent très compétitifs et cela en
incluant le coût des capacités de
flexibilité et de stockage chaque année
elles deviennent moins chères à
l'inverse le nucléaire lui devient de
plus en plus coûteux sans parler des
dettes laisser aux générations futures
en termes de déchets et de démantèlement
l'avenir n'est pas dans les paris
technologiques qui risquent de mettre
gravement à mal notre économie
s'il y a quelques apports positifs
adoptés il demeure très à la marge nous
notons tout de même à l'article 9 bis la
joue du rapporteur pour une meilleure
intégration de la cybersécurité dans la
sécurité nucléaire et mieux pour mieux
prendre en compte la résilience des
réacteurs au changement climatiques lors
de la demande d'autorisation de création
ainsi qu'au moment durée examen
décennales mais le risque de l'étude de
ville vulnérabilité ainsi prévu et
qu'elle ne porte que sur un temps très
court et ne prend pas en compte
l'échelle de vie de réacteur
l'ASM lui-même estime que le pas
décennale n'est pas adapté à
l'anticipation des effets du
réchauffement climatique il faut se
projeter jusqu'à la fin du siècle
seul réel motif de satisfaction l'unique
amendement du groupe écologiste adoptait
tendant à renforcer notre sécurité
collective en empêchant la construction
de nouvelles centrales nucléaires sur
des zones littorales vulnérables aux
inondations cette mesure de bon sens
doit être absolument maintenu la
problématique de l'eau impacte autant
les anciennes centrales que le nouveau
nucléaire le risque d'inondation ou de
submersion marine comme la baisse des
tâches des fleuves dans les années à
venir largement démontré par plusieurs
rapports sont des sujets centraux pour
la sûreté et pour la protection des
milieux naturels ce texte n’anticipe pas
suffisamment ses problématiques qui vont
se poser de plus en plus et c'est là que
l'on verra que le nucléaire est de plus
en plus intermittent pour conclure le
groupe écologiste s'oppose tant à
l'objectif comme modalité de ce texte
largement aggravée par son passage au
Sénat la modification de notre mix
énergétique est de donc de notre PPO
s'ajoute au détricotage du code de
l'urbanisme et du droit de
l'environnement pour de nouveaux
réacteurs dans le Parlement même pas
encore validé le principe nous sommes
clairement en Absurdie et son intérêts
par temps de dogmatisme et d'aveuglement
le groupe écologiste votera donc contre
ce texte qui va encore davantage relégué
au second plan l'indispensable
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
et les investissements dans la
rénovation thermique ce sont les seuls
capables de répondre aux enjeux
climatiques et à notre souveraineté
la parole est à notre collègue Bernard
lui pour le compte du rassemblement des
démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le 18 janvier dans
la nuit de mardi à mercredi après un peu
plus de 7 heures de débat nous avons
achevé l'examen du projet de loi portant
sur la construction de nouvelles
centrales nucléaires certains collègues
ont considéré que les débats n'étaient
pas assez nourris pourtant ces échanges
ont surtout révélé une certaine
convergence de vue entre nous sur ce
texte première pierre de l'immense
chantier pour la relance du nucléaire en
France mais ce projet de loi de
simplification des procédures et
techniques très techniques ce qui a
limité une inflation d'amendement et
ceux qui devait a priori éviter de longs
débats de fonds sur ceux qui nous
voulons pour notre mix énergétique débat
que nous aurions dû avoir et que nous
aurons l'été prochain lors de l'examen
de la loi de programmation énergie
climat je vais y revenir
alors que retenir du projet de loi après
son examen au Sénat
quelques désaccords sur le fond qui
risque d'amoindrir la portée des
articles et une véritable divergence
s'agissant de l'angle programmatique
ajoutée c'est donc sans sourciller que
la majorité sénatoriale supprime
l'objectif de réduction à 50 % de la
part du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité d'ici à 2035 tout en
imposant la révision du décret qui
prévoit la fermeture de 12 réacteurs
c'est sans trembler que la majorité
sénatoriale supprime le plafond autorisé
d'électricité nucléaire fixée à 63,2
gigawatts dans le code de l'énergie mes
chers collègues la question ne passe pas
de savoir si nous sommes pour ou contre
la relance du nucléaire à titre
personnel j'y suis très favorable au
fond il me semble que la question est
plutôt de comprendre pourquoi vouloir
balayer d'un revers de main les
consultations en cours peut-être par un
patience afin de marquer un
positionnement assumé profitant ainsi de
ce véhicule législatif pour donner
signal fort soucieux d'écouter la
majorité sédatorial reconnaissant que le
gouvernement a fait un geste en portant
un amendement visant à un meilleur
équilibre entre le nucléaire et les
énergies renouvelables un amendement
d'appel qui ne précise en rien le
rapport de cette équilibre car encore
une fois ce projet de loi n'est pas un
texte programmatique l'équilibre de ce
mix énergétique n'est pas et ne sera pas
l'objet de ce texte d'accélération des
procédures nous avons deux consultations
publiques en cours l'une menée par le
gouvernement dans le cadre d'une vaste
consultation publique qui s'est achevée
le 18 janvier à ce jour 31 355
contributions ont été reçues
cette concertation c'est poursuivie sous
la forme d'un forum des jeunesses à
Paris réunissant 200 jeunes de 18 à 35
ans sélectionnés dans toute la France
par tirage au sort l'autre consultation
animée par la Commission nationale du
débat public doit débattre sur la vie
l'avenir du nucléaire de demain elle a
démarré le 27 octobre et doit se
poursuivre jusqu'au 27 janvier prochain
prenons prendre les devants de ces
consultations ce n'est pas respectueux
vis-à-vis des contributions des citoyens
qui ont légitimement cru que leurs
paroles pouvait être prises en compte
avant le débat parlementaire d'ailleurs
sur ce point la CNDP a été très claire
en considérant que cette anticipation de
la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie revenez à considérer comme
sans intérêt les interrogations les
remarques et les propositions faites
lors du débat public en cours pour
définir la stratégie énergétique
nous attendons de la navette
parlementaire qu'elle revienne sur ses
dispositions afin de respecter ce temps
démocratique nécessaire à l'exception à
l'acceptation de notre nouvelle
stratégie énergétique aussi nous
regrettons que le Sénat est donné un peu
de plomb dans l'aile aux objectifs de
simplification du texte je pense par
exemple à l'article 3 concernant la
dispense d'autorisation d'urbanisme les
précisions apportées en décret au
Conseil d'État crée désormais un quasi
nouveau régime d'autorisation
contre-productif je pense à l'Autorité
de sûreté nucléaire dans le cadre de la
délivrance de l'autorisation
environnementale dont l'apport semble
peu pertinent pour les textes
préparatoires au chantier je pense au
dispositions visant à soumettre à
autorisation les ouvrages de
raccordement des procédures qui
retarderaient l'autorisation de
nouvelles installations
électronucléaires
au total ce sont 10 points d'alerte que
nous avons souhaité signaler à la
majorité sénatoriale susceptible d'être
contraire aux objectifs de
simplification de la loi résultat final
10 amendements rejetés nous en prenons
acte nous espérons là encore que
l'Assemblée nationale sera plus
réceptive à nos contributions ces
remarques étant faites en responsabilité
nous voterons toutefois le texte émanant
du Sénat car nous partageons plus
d'objectifs que de divergence notre
groupe souhaite reprendre la grande
aventure du nucléaire civile et beaucoup
d'entre vous partager cet objectif cela
sera d'abord pas en lit en
Seine-Maritime pour une première mise en
service envisagée entre 2035 et 2037
puis Gravelines et dans la vallée du
Rhône à ce sujet je vous réaffirme mon
souhait d'accueillir de nouveaux EPR à
Tricastin ou tout un bassin d'emplois
est prêt à se retrousser les marches
pour participer à cette nouvelle
aventure nucléaire nous en prenons
conscience les besoins en main d'oeuvre
qualifiés sont immenses pour rénover le
parc comme pour mener à bien les projets
nouveaux réacteurs il est question de
recruter sur la période 2023 2030 un
minimum de 10 à 15000 personnes par an
au lieu des 5000 annuels entre 2019 et
2022 pour ce qui est des ressources
humaines l'enjeu est considérable depuis
2020 200 millions d'euros ont été
consacrés à la formation dans cette
filière dans notre région nous
anticipons aussi ces bouleversements un
centre de formation aux métiers du
nucléaire ouvrira ses portes en
septembre 2023 à La Voulte-sur-Rhône en
Ardèche en bordure de la Drôme je fais
ici un clin d'oeil à mes collègues
ardéchois Matthieu d'Arnaud et Anne
vantalon
ce centre devrait accueillir 80 élèves
chaque année ce centre permettra aux
élèves de se former dans différents
métiers dont a besoin d'industrie
nucléaire comme la chaudronnerie la
soudure l'usinage ou encore
l'électricité un centre de formation
d'autant plus nécessaire que ces métiers
de technicien et d'opérateurs ne sont
pas suffisamment pourvus dans la filière
contrairement au poste d'ingénieurs pour
conclure mes chers collègues en
attendant ne nous exprimer sur notre
trajectoire énergétique ce projet de loi
sera essentiel pour accélérer actualiser
et dépoussiérer des procédures qui pour
certaines d'entre elles datent de 50 ans
alors mes chers collègues votant ce
projet de loi rien que ce projet de loi
tout ce projet de loi
merci
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Franck Montauger pour le groupe
socialiste
écologiste et républicain
vous savez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre et chers collègues au nom du
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains je voudrais ici rappeler le
contexte et les objectifs qui étaient
les nôtres dans la discussion de ce
texte visant à accélérer la construction
d'installation nucléaire sur site
existant ou à proximité le contexte
c'est celui de 5 années de désintérêt de
tergiversations au plus haut niveau de
l'État qui débouche en février 2022 sur
une décision de commande de ferme de 6
EPR 2 et de mise à l'étude de 8 unités
supplémentaires avec l'espoir d'une
hypothétique mise en service en 2035 au
mieux et cela sans avoir lancé de débat
ou de consultation un temps soit peu
démocratique avec les premiers concernés
nos compatriotes pendant des années nous
avons sollicité sans cesse les
gouvernements les uns après les autres
pour engager ce débat avec les Français
et ici au Parlement avec vous
nous vous avons interpellé madame la
ministre sur la nécessité de prendre le
temps d'un débat approfondi sur le mix
énergétique à faire évoluer au regard de
la sortie nécessaire des énergies
fossiles sans cesse nous avons rappelé
la situation alarmante de DF et la crise
de l'énergie que nous voyons ce
développer bien avant la crise
géopolitique européenne actuelle les
objectifs quelle organisation pour les
énergéticiens français bientôt peut-être
100% public après Hercule et grandes EDF
toujours aucun échange sur le fond avec
vous qui représentez l'État dans le
cadre de quelle stratégie avec quels
moyens financier pour servir quels
objectifs de souveraineté industrielle
dans l'intérêt premier des consommateurs
particuliers professionnels et
industriels sur la base de quelles
proposition française de réforme du
marché européen un marché qui a fait de
la démonstration de son Ida inadéquation
aux intérêts stratégiques des États
membres et de l'Union européenne en
discussion générale je disais que nous
ne voulions pas que ce que ce soit le
prétexte d'un pseudo débat d'affichage
sur une partie fut-elle importante du
mix énergétique dont la France a
urgemment besoin pour répondre aux
enjeux climatiques
sans débat de fonds entre nous sur ce
que pourrait être ou devrait être le mix
énergétique la majorité sénatoriale à
élargi le périmètre du texte
initialement consacré à la
simplification des procédures de
délivrance des autorisation nous nous
sommes opposés à ce changement de
périmètre pourquoi parce que ce débat ne
peut pas être traité à la légère ici au
Parlement au détour et en quelques
heures de discussion d'un texte qui ne
lui est pas pleinement consacré et qui
n'a pas été préparé pour cela
à tout le moins convenait Jean une
solide étude d'impact est nécessaire
s'appuyant au moins sur les études
robustes de RTE ou de l'ADEME notamment
et là pour le seuil des 50% comme pour
celui des 63,2 gigawatts rien parce que
nous ne sommes plus dans les années 60
ou 70 et que ce débat intéresse et
concerne aussi l'ensemble des Français
parce que comme le prévoit la charte
constitutionnelle de l’environnement les
Français ont à connaître et doivent
pouvoir discuter des politiques
énergétiques et climatiques qui
conditionneront la durabilité si ce
n'est la viabilité du monde de demain à
contrario du trop peu de considération
c'est un euphémisme qui a été fait de la
convention citoyenne sur le climat nous
devons respecter les débats en cours de
la Commission nationale du débat public
sur l'avenir énergétique du pays et la
composition de notre futur mix
énergétique ainsi que les consultations
sur les nouveaux EPR 2
respecter la dimension collective ou
participative de notre démocratie ne
nous permet pas d'anticiper sur le
contenu de la future loi quinquennale
qui sera examinée par le Parlement en
2023 le mix devra résulter de notre team
combinant les différents modes de
production disponibles tout en que
tenant compte de leurs impacts
spécifiques divers et donc né cartons a
priori aucun moyen de production des
carbonées dans une perspective d'emploi
et de souveraineté nationale nous devons
nous donner l'objectif de filière
industrielle implantées dans nos
territoires la formation et la
reconnaissance des métiers devront être
notre priorité et cela pour chaque mode
de production au plan technique les
possibilités de prolongation des
réacteurs pèseront lourd dans le mix
retenu elles ne sont pas connues au
moment où on parle l'ASN ne les a pas
instruite à ce jour et au moment où nous
parlons beaucoup d'incertitudes
technologiques vous vous avez reste
aussi à lever en considération de ces
différents aspects soyons réalistes et
rationnels afin de prendre une position
politique éclairée dont les effets
seront majeurs sur le long terme c'est
la position de principe du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
quant au débat tout le jamendement de
retour au périmètre initial ont été
rejetés nous avons aussi voulu porter le
débat sur des points de vigilance qui
méritent attention ce relatif à la
nécessaire prise en compte des aléas
climatiques extrêmes ressources à nous
traits de côtes inondations etc sujet
qui avec d'autres conditionneront la
performance et la sécurité du parc de
production nucléaire dans les décennies
à venir
[Musique]
être réel et utile est aussi à
relativiser il permettra de gagner une
année voire deux au mieux après que le
pays en ai perdu 5 sur le sujet et pour
des installations industrielles dans la
durée de vie je le rappelle pourrait
être de 60 ans ou plus en conséquence le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains s'abstiendra et nous vous
demandons par un travail approfondi et
dès maintenant avec le Parlement madame
la ministre d’engager sans tarder le
processus de révision du mix énergétique
national je vous remercie merci
je vais donner la parole de notre
collègue Fabien gay pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues dès l'ouverture de
la discussion générale de ce texte nous
avons émis un certain nombre de réserves
sur la forme d'abord parce que nous
regrettons que rien ne change sur votre
méthode nous vivons une crise sans
précédent dans le constat est clair et
demande une réponse globale aujourd'hui
c'est un système concurrentiel qui
s'effondre et qui n'a jamais tenu par
lui-même dans lequel il a toujours fallu
intervenir pour qu'elle semblant de
concurrence émerge et quelles
concurrence des fournisseurs alternatifs
dopés aux aides d'État indirects
propulsé par l'assèchement organisé de
l'opérateur historique EDF un marché
européen l'électricité ou sont invités
traders et spéculation et où la fraude
est massive des valeurs marchandes sans
réalité concrète des échanges sans stock
des factures sans lien avec les mixtes
électriques nationaux un fiasco pour les
usagers et les usagers pour l'innovation
pour l'investissement pour le
développement des énergies des carbonées
cette situation personne ne peut
l'ignorer tant la crise la rendue
visible les collectivités les
entreprises les artisans et commerçants
et particuliers personne n'est épargné
mais un choc n'est jamais une fatalité
lorsqu'on prend la mesure de ce qui se
produit lorsque l'on accepte qu'il faut
changer de logiciel on peut rebâtir
quelque chose on peut régler la question
efficacement et durablement ce n'est pas
l'approche que vous avez retenu madame
la ministre vous continuez de penser
qu'il est possible de continuer sur un
traitement partiel des enjeux autour de
l'énergie texte par texte projet de loi
après projet de loi sans remettre en
question le cadre global mais ce n'est
pas possible tous les groupes ici vous
l'ont dit d'ailleurs les sensibilités
politiques sont loin d'être les mêmes
mais tout est tous vous en reproché la
méthode avec laquelle vous abordez le
sujet six mois avant la programmation
plus réelle de l'énergie vous nous
présentez un texte pour réduire les
délais administratifs sur le nucléaire
en réalité ces symptomatiques de quelque
chose ces symptomatiques du rôle du
Parlement aux yeux de votre gouvernement
une chambre d'enregistrement selon vous
devant laquelle vous faites passer des
textes parce que la Constitution vous le
demande mais ce n'est pas le débat qui
vous intéresse d'ailleurs le mieux selon
vous c'est de ne pas amender mais madame
la ministre la filière nucléaire n'a pas
souffert des délais administratifs elle
a souffert des haters moments des
gouvernements successifs et de la
volonté de mettre fin à cette filière
du côté des communistes nous soutenons
le développement du nucléaire comme
celui des énergies renouvelables mais à
deux conditions démocratie et sécurité
faire passer un texte alors que le débat
public n'est pas fini sur le nucléaire
non ce n'est pas sérieux pire la
réduction des délais administratifs
risquent de provoquer colère et
incompréhension alors que ce sont des
projets qui vont s'étendre sur un siècle
on a besoin de prendre le temps de la
concertation de l'acceptabilité et vous
avez un autre problème imaginez que le
Parlement décide de retenir le scénario
le scénario de RTE 100% renouvelable
dans la PPE ce n'est pas notre volonté
mais imaginons-le nous aurons donc passé
du temps à bavarder pour rien d'ailleurs
vous avez passé 8 minutes sur les 11 de
votre intervention générale au début du
texte pour nous expliquer ce dont il ne
fallait pas parler à savoir l'essentiel
et important en réalité sur ce projet de
loi il aurait fallu s'en tenir au
secondaire et au superficiel et si le
Parlement ose amender ou si vous êtes
minoritaire c'est soit la procédure
accélérée soit le 49-3 l'Assemblée
nationale soit comme vous le faites
actuellement avec l'article 47-1 sur les
retraites venons donc au fond sur le
financement d'abord du nucléaire
interdit d'en parler c'est une chose de
modifier un article du code de
l'urbanisme ça n'est une autre de savoir
comment financer huit nouveaux EPR à
plusieurs milliards d'euros avec d'EDF
nous aurions une maîtrise publique via
un groupe prêtatisé mais nous voulons
savoir quelle sera la nouvelle
architecture du groupe EDF là aussi
interdit d'en parler ce n'est pas
l'ordre du jour permettez-moi de vous
dire que les parlementaires que nous
sommes dans notre diversité ont le droit
de s'interroger sur les capacités d'un
groupe à investir alors qu'il a déjà 60
milliards d'euros de dettes et beaucoup
dû à la reine mais non passez votre
chemin le gouvernement s'occupe de tout
et quelle régulation de ce nouveau
nucléaire avec la reine 2.0 après 2025
là où quand interdit d'en parler on nous
répond que les négociations ont commencé
d'ailleurs on ne sait même pas avec qui
pourtant c'est un sujet sur lequel on ne
peut pas faire l'économie de la
réflexion dans ce système est absurde et
insupportable par exemple trois
questions est-ce que vous allez
continuer à ruiner EDF avec un système
comme la reine est-ce que est-ce que
vous allez nous faire voter pour des
installations nucléaires d'EDF qui
n'aura même pas les moyens de les
entretenir et est-ce que le service
public va continuer d'être racketté au
profit d'acteurs alternatif privé
ensuite
la question fondamentale concerne les
tarifs réglementés de vente de
l'électricité et pourtant pas Mo
interdit d'en parler madame la ministre
êtes-vous pour leur maintien ou pour y
mettre un terme comme avec le gaz au 30
juin 2023 ce ne sont pas des questions
annexes c'est le cœur du sujet enfin sur
les enjeux de sécurité d'emploi pas un
mot sur les travailleurs et
travailleuses de la filière ni pour
celles et ceux qui font les frais de la
sous-traitance en cascade nous vous
avons interrogé sur le sujet et vous
nous avez répondu il ne rêve pas tout et
tous d'être au statut de l'easio je le
redis et je l'assume nous ne devons pas
rencontrer les mêmes travailleurs et
travailleuses nous nous exigeons avec
elle et eux de ce statut soit
sanctuarisé et élargi à tous les
sous-traitants il en va de leur sécurité
et aussi de la nôtre et de
l'attractivité des filières de la
reconnaissance de leur travail et de
leur qualification parce qu'il faut être
clair la décennie de retard de l'EPR de
Flamanville ne vient pas des lenteurs
administratives mais en grande partie de
la case des métiers des savoir-faire et
des compétences et tout ceci a été
précipité par le recours abusif au
sous-traitants alors comme pour les
énergies renouvelables nous défendons un
nucléaire de haut niveau et non pas un
low cost nous voulons construire notre
indépendance sur ces deux piliers sous
maîtrise publique et nous appuyer sur
nos propres savoir-faire compétences et
filières car pour nous l'énergie étant
bien comme un l'humanité et doit être
sorti des griffes du marché pour toutes
ces raisons oui un nucléaire de haut
niveau mais non comment vous le faites
donc nous nous abstiendrons
merci
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue Amel
gaker pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
la ministre chers collègues la situation
du mix énergétique français et désormais
bien connu 62% de notre consommation
d'énergie repose encore sur les énergies
fossiles massivement importés le conflit
Russo ukrainien et ses conséquences en
matière d'approvisionnement en
hydrocarbures a mis en lumière notre
dépendance et l'impérieuse nécessité
d'une production énergétique autonome la
question de l'énergie n'est pas nouvelle
elle est vitale point de transport point
de développement industriel point
d'agriculture peu d'activités humaines
demeure possible sans approvisionnement
énergétique et pourtant
il a fallu une crise géopolitique en
Europe et l'explosion du coût de
l'énergie son impact sur les dépenses
des ménages la situation économique
délicate voire catastrophique dans
laquelle se trouve nombre de nos
artisans de nous entreprises pour que le
sujet soit enfin abordé et bien sûr dans
l'urgence face aux multiples enjeux qui
s'imposent à nous enjeux de souveraineté
énergétiques deux baisses programmées de
la consommation d'énergie fossiles la
nécessité de développer une énergie bas
carbone et bien sûr l'objectif d'une
grande efficacité énergétique le
nucléaire doit être le fer de lance de
la politique
énergétique française pour les 30 années
à venir nous n'avons pas le choix seule
la construction d'un mix énergétique à
Lyon un nucléaire pilotable à des
énergies renouvelables diversifiées
compétitives nous permettra d'envisager
un avenir plus serein pour nos
concitoyens nous entreprises et pour
notre planète
exclusivement technique ce projet de loi
d'accélération du nucléaire et bien sûr
le bienvenu il met en lumière un sujet
primordial mais laisse de regrettable
zone d'ombre je ne m'attarde pas
longuement sur le joyeux des ordres qui
règne dans le calendrier parlementaire
de la politique énergétique désormais à
chaque saison son projet de loi
énergétique l'automne nous a offert les
énergies renouvelables l'hiver le
nucléaire et le début de l'été nous
permettra d'examiner une loi de
programmation au contour complètement
inconnu une saisonnalité regrettable
conduisant notre politique énergétique à
être au mieux illisible ou au pire
incohérentes je ne reviendrai pas non
plus dans le détail sur les actes
manqués de ce texte d'une technicité
rare et au caractère politique illimité
voire inexistant des questions centrales
ne sont pas abordées
je rejoins certains de mes collègues
notamment sur le financement des futurs
investissements colossaux vers quel
modèle
souhaitez-vous aller un des enjeux étant
de garantir un coût maîtrisé de
l'électricité quid des réacteurs
existants qui ne tourneront pas
indéfiniment qu'en est-il de la question
des compétences cela a été dit je le
redis de la formation des personnels
sans qui la relance sera impossible
enfin je ne m'arrêterai pas non plus
longuement sur les questions soulevées
quant à l'avenir dans notre capacité de
production électro-nucléaire selon RTL
notre mix énergétique devra être composé
à 50%, 55% d'électricité contre 25%
aujourd'hui celle-ci est en produite à
70% par nos centrales nucléaires il nous
faudra augmenter notre capacité de
production les 14 réacteurs évoqués par
le Président nous permettrait
d'augmenter légèrement nos capacités de
production mais
inévitablement des réacteurs construits
dans les années 70 et 80 fermeront mes
chers collègues vous l'avez compris le
conte n'y est pas il nous faut donc être
bien plus ambitieux pour relever le défi
je souhaite néanmoins revenir sur le
travail sénatorial de fond et de qualité
autour du projet de loi initiale qui a
permis de consolider la scie juridique
du nucléaire existant ainsi que le cadre
des projets à venir donc je salue
clairement
l'excellent travail effectué par nous
rapporteurs Daniel grommier Pascal
Martin ainsi que celui des commissions
des affaires économiques et du
développement durable je le rappelle
encore une fois en un temps record je
souhaite relever ici quelques points
essentiels
issus de ce travail notamment la
suppression par le sida de l'objectif de
réduction à 50% du nucléaire dans la
production d'électricité d'ici 2035
le déplafonnement de la capacité de
production d'électricité nucléaire qui
avait été introduit dans la loi de 2015
est également à saluer une mesure qui
laisserait peu de marge de manœuvre pour
le développement du nucléaire en France
un ensemble face aux défis de hausse de
consommation d'électricité et de
réindustrialisation qui s'impose à nous
autres avancée l'extension à l'horizon
2050 de la durée d'application des
mesures contenues dans ce texte
disposition qui permettra de doter le
nucléaire d'une vision stratégique plus
claire sur le long terme et surtout
qu'on pourra à l'attractivité de la
filière essentielle pour donner envie à
nos jeunes d'investir les formations
nécessaires à leur relance du nucléaire
autre point positif une meilleure prise
en compte de la vie des collectivités
territoriales dans la mise en
compatibilité des documents d'urbanisme
lorsqu'un projet de réacteur est à
l'étude cela était demandé dans nos
territoires ces choses faites et c'est
un vrai pas en avant nous devons bâtir
notre stratégie énergétique avec
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés et cela
débute au niveau local enfin la
consolidation de la procédure de
l'examen des réacteurs nucléaires
au-delà de leur 35e année de
fonctionnement est inévitable afin de
garantir un bon
entretien bonne entretien du parc
existant ah non je crucial au regard des
polémiques récentes sur l'état de
celui-ci les risques de délestage
évoquer cet hiver et toujours
d'actualité d'ailleurs chers collègues
sous l'impulsion de nous rapporteurs
nous avons fait évoluer ce texte
technique afin de faciliter concrètement
la construction de futurs réacteurs
l'année 2023 doit être celle de la
relance du nucléaire français
parallèlement au développement des
énergies renouvelables donc avec mes
collègues du groupe de l'Union centriste
nous serons à ce titre
particulièrement vigilant lors de
l'examen de la prochaine programmation
plus réelle de l'énergie prévue cet été
afin que le gouvernement passe des
paroles aux actes sans éluder bien sûr
les questions essentielles
d'approvisionnement
uranium de gestion des déchets de sûreté
de recherche et développement madame la
ministre nous voterons ce projet de loi
amendé car il entend participer à la
relance de la filière nucléaire en
France mais vous l'avez compris ce n'est
synonyme ni d'une carte blanche ni d'un
blanc sain je vous remercie de votre
écoute
merci ma chère collègue
j'ai donné la parole
de notre collègue Jean-Louis Masson pour
la Réunion administrative des sénateurs
ne figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe
voilà
ce sont
se dirige vers la tribune
mes chers collègues si nous sommes
confrontés actuellement à une crise
économique importante à une inflation
galopante c'est en grande partie parce
qu'un certain nombre de responsables
politiques ont torpillé le programme
nucléaire français parce que la grande
source il faut dire la vérité la grande
source du de la crise économique
actuelle c'est l'explosion de l'énergie
et l'explosion de l'énergie c'est parce
qu'il y a eu des irresponsables si ce
sont battus qui ont voulu faire croire
que l'énergie nucléaire c'était plus
dangereux qu'autre chose moi j'ai été à
la fois par le passé ingénieur des mines
c'est contrôler les mines de charbon et
j'étais aussi inspecteur des
installations nucléaires et je peux vous
dire que à quantité d'énergie égale
produite une mine de charbon est à
l'origine de 50 fois plus de morts
simplement il y a 10 morts 20 morts
c'est pas des morts d'un seul coup mais
50 fois plus de morts que disons des des
centrales nucléaires alors on a fait de
la démagogie nos collègues
écologistes qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
ils ont transformé le nucléaire en un
fonds de commerce politicien ils savent
très bien les écologistes savent très
bien que la meilleure solution pour
lutter contre le gaz carbonique c'est
pas d'installer des moulins à vent c'est
d'installer des structures qui
produisent de l'énergie en quantité qui
produisent de l'énergie à bas coût parce
que on veut nous faire croire maintenant
que les éoliennes c'est rentable les
éoliennes sont rentables parce que le
prix de l'électricité a doublé sinon les
éoliennes ne seraient pas rentables et
je pense qu'il y a donc là une
responsabilité colossale les écologistes
sont sympathiques lorsque sont des
hommes de base lorsque les écologistes
sont des politiciens ce des catastrophes
il pourrissent la vie il
pourrissent la vie de nos concitoyens
que ce soit les zones de les zones de
lutte contre les contre les soi-disant
pollution automobile et autres ils
pourrissent la ville de nos concitoyens
alors mes chers collègues moi je dis une
chose il faut relancer
les centrales nucléaires donc la
production il faut relancer la
production de l'électricité nucléaire
c'est fondamental et ce projet de loi
est excellent je crois que le Sénat sur
ce point a fait un très bon travail bien
entendu je le vaut très et je devrais
terminer en vous dirant une chose
importante mes chers collègues ce qu'il
faut c'est tourner au maximum la molette
du développement des centrales
nucléaires
merci
allez
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
il va être procédé
dans les conditions prévues par
l'article 56 de notre règlement au
scrutin public solennel sur l'ensemble
du projet de loi relatif
à l'accélération des procédures liées à
la construction de nouvelles
installations nucléaires le scrutin sera
ouvert dans quelques instants
dès maintenant vous insérez votre carte
de vote dans le terminal
et vous le laissez
jusqu'au vote
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est donc clos
voici les résultats du scrutin numéro
110 donc de votant 333 donc de suffrages
exprimé 255 pour l'adoption 239 contre
16 le Sénat a adopté le projet de loi
je vais donner maintenant la parole à
madame la ministre
à Madame Agnès paniere une ministre de
la transition énergétique
merci Monsieur le monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs je
suis a été d'abord vous remercier pour
le travail sur le texte en particulier
évidemment les rapporteurs Daniel
grimillet Pascal Martin les présidents
de commission Sophie prima et
Jean-François Longeot et tous les
membres des deux commissions à faire
économiques et développement durable et
aménagement du territoire
comme vous l'avez très bien dit c'est le
deuxième texte énergétique et examiné en
trois mois au Sénat et à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est la marque de notre
détermination collective détermination
collective à préparer collectivement
l'avenir énergétique de notre pays
détermination à sortir de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles et aux
puissances étrangères parfois hostiles
en produisant des énergies décarbonées
sur notre territoire et je rappelle
contrairement à ce qu'on entend que nous
sommes dépendants 2/3 des énergies
fossiles et que rien de nouveau sous le
soleil cela et la situation depuis plus
de 50 ans
détermination aussi à répondre aux
enjeux de pouvoir d'achat des Français
et de compétitivité de nos entreprises
car c'est en produisant de l'énergie à
bas coût qu'on va résoudre le problème
du prix d'électricité quel est quel que
soit le design de marché enfin
détermination à faire de notre pays un
grand pays de l'énergie souverain dans
ces technologies et qui exportent et je
crois que beaucoup seront sensibles à
cet objectif nous allons dans quelques
mois examiner la prochaine loi de
programmation énergique climat j'entends
beaucoup d'impatience pour l'examen de
cette loi c'est une très bonne chose je
crois qu'il nous faut respecter le débat
public beaucoup l'ont rappelé ici ce
débat public qui vise et que vous avez
voulu puisque c'est vous qui l'avez
institué dans les textes qui vise à
interroger le français est en train de
s'achever il vous sera transmis par la
voix d'une synthèse de la Commission
nationale du débat public et il vous
permettra de prendre les bons réglages
en fait connaissance de cause il ne
m'appartient donc pas en tant que
gouvernement de porter aujourd'hui une
vision d'un futur PPE programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie puisqu'elle
viendra après en revanche je redis notre
souhait de construire cette
ce mix énergétique sur trois pieds la
baisse de la consommation d'énergie car
et ce n'est pas moi qui le dise c'est le
GIAC ce sont les experts c'est le
premier c'est la première façon de
construire une indépendance énergétique
de baisser notre consommation d'énergie
par l'efficacité énergétique et par la
sobriété et bien sûr la production
d'électricité de chaleur renouvelable
sur notre territoire et d'électricité
par le biais des renouvelables et le
nucléaire tout cela est très clair et
nous aurons l'occasion d'y travailler
très prochainement je mettrai en place
des groupes de travail très en amont de
la prochaine programmation car je vois
bien à quel point il est important que
chacun soit parti prenante de ce débat
essentiel des stratégique vous l'avez
chacun votre manière dit lors de cette
explication de vote merci à tous merci
madame la ministre
[Applaudissements]
je vais maintenant suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 15h50 pour la
désignation des membres d'une commission
d'enquête et d'une mission d'information
puis l'examen du projet de loi relatif
aux Jeux Olympiques paralympiques de
2024 la séance c'est donc suspendue